is he's telling me i used to struggle
reading the quran daily before you
instructed instructed me to download
this app brothers and sisters can you
imagine someone struggling and he has
downloaded the quran app and built a
habit and now he's regularly reading you
can go into the description box click
the link for ios and android and build
your habit with the quran right now
yep i know it's fake just like the media
just like the media
i think this is the first video that i
will be ever doing that i will be
allowed
legally
yeah i'll be legally allowed to praise a
fellow muslim woman hijabi and her
husband
for the actions that they did
which is what
literally trying to assassinate putin
you know
and
this is very bizarre because if you
think about it i'm going to make the
most out of this because i don't think
if i ever did this with the issues of
afghanistan
palestine yemen iraq or the uyghurs in
china if i was to ever praise
a muslim woman or a man
trying to fight those who are oppressing
them i would have been arrested my child
would be shut down my citizenship may
have been revoked god knows what else i
might be imprisoned by now but that's
where i'm going to take this opportunity
to praise this woman who is this woman
this is sister
also known as sniper amina akuev a
coefficient i think that's what i'm
called this is what daily mail says can
you imagine as daily mail praising her
dressed to kill ukrainian sniper married
to a soldier accused of plotting to
assassinate putin raise his eyebrows
let's learn a bit about herself and i
saw this video
on a this post on brother weissenberg's
page her and her husband she was married
three times each of the time her husband
passed away so they said in ukraine and
nina became a representative of the the
zorka dude
battalion the veteran chechen volunteer
force that fought russia during the
first and second chechen wars named
after the former anti-anti-russian
chechen president amina studied amir
studied medicine at odessa med medical
university and graduated
specializing in general surgery when
trouble began with russia back
when trouble began with russian-backed
groups in luhansk and donetsk amina
participated alongside her church
brothers as a medic sniper for kiev ii
battalion and fought in several battles
several battles amina survived survived
one assassination attempt on her during
which her husband was shot but both were
saved due to her quick response after
she pulled out her handgun and shot the
assailant however in a second similar
ambush in 2017 her husband was wounded
and she was killed by assassin with two
bullets to her head there there are at
least two streets in kiev this is in
ukraine prince princip in kiev
principality principality of ukraine
named after this extraordinary sister
this is absolutely amazing guys and some
streets are named after her for her
bravery
now this is the point brothers and
sisters at the time of the prophet
muhammed peace be upon him there were
many companions female companies who
were involved in war as well to defend
the muslims against oppression but the
pictures you see me you see on my left
are the pictures where she was on the
ground on the ground
literally there with her husband
fighting russia
and putin
and subhanallah this is exactly when we
talk about the concept of jihad this is
what we're talking about fighting the
oppressors those who are oppressing the
muslims okay yeah in a legitimate
islamic country by the way not your you
know i declare myself a state a new
fight under me not nonsense none of that
okay this is done under a legal uh
rulership a muslim rulership okay not
your i made my little crew and we're
gonna go and do uh all that kind of
nonsense of absolutely not and
targeting innocent people as well no
this is combat towards those who are
being combat towards combatants because
we know the massacre russia did in
chechnya okay we know what happened in
bosnia by the serbs may allah destroy
and deal with these scums okay
but
the main video the reason why i did this
video is just to point out that as
muslims this is the only time maybe that
we can ever praise
a soldier a muslim and a female soldier
that we can outrightly praise and say
may allah grant them the highest ranks
of jannah for their bravery
for true heroes they are that they
fought against the oppressors
and sadly were made shaheed inshallah
and we ask allah subhanahu wa tala to
grant in the highest ranks of jannah
what a woman subhanallah what a woman
somebody that you can salute
what a woman that she subhanallah
goes out there she observes the hijab
yeah she observes a hijab she has
obedience to her lord and when it comes
to defending
her rights her honor her country
and she did exactly that by taking arms
and going to the very battlefield
where in today's time god knows how many
men would even dare to imagine you know
to go to the battlefield she bravely
bravely
was side by side with her husband like
they say the enemy of my enemy is my
friend
so
since russia is also our enemy and the
west
we have some perks with that which is
these videos and praising individuals
like sister amina and her husband and
bear in mind she was married first time
and her husband died then she married
again and the husband died and then she
married again
these are the kind of sisters that we
should all look up to subhanallah may
allah bless her and her husbands who
have all passed away and grant them the
highest ranks of jannah that's all i
have to say brother sisters in this very
specific video inshallah share this far
round wide so people can truly see
the muslim woman and what islam
and how islam increases their ranks
subhan allah till next time
assalamualaikum warahmatullahi